-The Justice Department
subpoenaed
Donald Trump's former
chief of staff, Mark Meadows,
and Meadows is reportedly
complying with that subpoena,
making him the highest-ranking
Trump official so far
to respond to a federal subpoena
in the criminal investigation
of the attempted coup
on January 6th.
There are also bombshell
new text messages
in a very bizarre scandal
involving former NFL quarterback
and Trump supporter Brett Favre
that reveal just how corrupt
the conservative movement
has become.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
You know, it took
like two full years,
but it really seems like
the Justice Department
is finally kicking it into gear
when it comes to these
Trump investigations.
They're seizing phones,
sending out dozens of subpoenas,
and executing search warrants.
I don't know what changed.
Merrick Garland used to seem
like one of those
movie detectives
on cruise control
because he was only a month away
from collecting a pension,
and now he's like a renegade cop
on a Harley in a leather jacket
who kicks in doors
and holds perps out windows
while hissing, "You can either
tell me what happened
or your brains can tell
the pavement."
[ Laughter ]
The point is,
the DOJ's Trump investigation
seems to be rapidly
intensifying.
For example, yesterday,
we told you a...
well, a truly heartwarming story
about a delightful young man
named Mike Lindell, who had his
phone seized by the FBI
while he was at
a Hardee's drive-through.
As he explained in a video,
the FBI agents at the scene
told him not to talk about it,
but he did anyway.
-The FBI came after me
and took my phone.
They surrounded me
at a Hardee's
and took my phone that I run all
my business, everything with.
Um, they could've just...
What they've done
is weaponized the FBI.
It's disgusting.
I don't have a computer.
Everything I do off that phone.
Everything was on there,
and, um...
And they told me
not to tell anybody.
Here's an order not to.
"Don't tell anybody."
Okay. I won't.
[ Chuckles ]
Well, I am.
So, there you go.
-Well, that is just the kind
of recklessness
I would expect from
a 61-year-old man
who eats at Hardee's.
[ Laughter ]
Also, I doubt that paper
says the words,
"Don't tell anybody."
It's an order from the FBI,
not a note
passed in fifth grade.
I bet that piece of paper isn't
even an order from the FBI.
In fact, if you zoom in,
you can see
it's actually just a letter
from Hardee's that reads...
But also, when we first played
this clip yesterday,
there was a very
revealing detail
I glossed over
and want to revisit.
-Everything I do off that phone.
Everything was on there.
-It was?
Well, then, I guess...
jackpot, FBI!
[ Laughter ]
Usually you'd need to raid
multiple offices and homes
and sift through every box,
closet, and drawer
you can find for hours.
But not with Mike Lindell.
[As Lindell] Yeah, I keep it all
on my Motorola flip --
texts, call logs,
lists of crimes
both completed and planned,
in all my pictures.
I don't trust the cloud,
or any clouds,
'cause they look like
big fluffy pillows,
but in reality,
they're filled with...
da air!
[Normal voice]
Now, you might...
you might be wondering
which of the many
Trump investigations
the Lindell raid
was specifically related to.
Well, it's a very bizarre
and complicated story.
But basically, federal agents
apparently wanted to know more
about Lindell's potential
connections to a plot concocted
by a pro-Trump clerk
in Mesa County, Colorado,
named Tina Peters,
who was indicted earlier this
year for election tampering,
among other things.
Basically, Peters wanted
to prove that the 2020 election
was tampered with,
and in the process,
she herself allegedly tampered
with election equipment
by breaching voting machines.
Imagine being wily enough
to impersonate an IT consultant
and then dumb enough to be
in cahoots with Mike Lindell.
"Mike, it's Tina.
The feds are on to me.
But don't worry --
I've encrypted each
and every one
of our communications
and put them behind
multiple firewalls."
[as Lindell]
Good to hear, Tina!
I got everything you ever said
to me on the one phone,
and also, I put in my five
under "Crime Tina."
[ Laughter ]
[Normal voice]
So, at this point,
one can only assume
the Justice Department already
has at its disposal
a wealth of information
related to the coup attempt
on January 6th,
the various figures
involved in it,
and the machinations
that led up to it,
especially after
the newest revelations
we learned last night that
Trump's former chief of staff,
Mark Meadows,
has also been subpoenaed
and has responded
to that subpoena.
-We are learning that former
Trump White House
Chief of Staff Mark Meadows
has complied with a subpoena
from the Justice Department's
investigation into events
surrounding January 6th.
So, this makes him the
highest-ranking Trump official,
Trump administration official
that's known to have responded
to a subpoena
in this federal investigation.
-So far, Mark Meadows,
the president--
former President Trump's
chief of staff,
has complied
with the DOJ subpoena
by turning over documents,
the same documents
that he turned over
to the January 6 committee.
-Wow, even Trump's former
chief of staff
is turning over documents now.
And this is a guy, by the way,
who is, by all accounts,
always on his phones.
In July, he was spotted
walking around D.C.
while reporters shouted
questions at him
about the January 6 hearing,
and for the most part,
refused to look up
from his phone.
He looks like me
when my kids are demanding
to go to the beach.
"Yeah, sure, sure.
We can go to the beach.
I just need to set
my fantasy lineup
and check out the new memes.
Then I want to see
some Instagram ads
from sneaker companies that
only exist on Instagram ads."
[ Laughter ]
Of course, the only thing
stranger than Meadows'
refusal to look up
from his phone
was the fact that he was wearing
a fleece outdoors in July.
Do you know
how hot it was in July?
It was so hot that
during one show
I wore a sweater
and nothing else.
You just couldn't see
because of the desk.
Although it was a little jarring
when I got up
to greet the guests.
Now, you might remember Meadows
as the guy who was in many ways
at the center
of the attempted coup,
who, among other things,
arranged various
coup-related meetings
and sent insane
conspiracy theories
about vote tampering
with the Justice Department.
Meadows was also, according to
the people around him,
extremely checked out
in the days
leading up to the insurrection.
Former Trump aide
Cassidy Hutchinson
recalled after Rudy Giuliani
told her about the plan
to march to the Capitol,
she asked Meadows
about that plan,
and Meadows once again did not
even look up from his phone.
-After Mr. Giuliani had left
the campus that evening,
I went back up to our office
and I found Mr. Meadows
in his office on the couch.
He was scrolling
through his phone.
I remember leaning against
the doorway and saying,
"Just had an interesting
conversation with Rudy, Mark.
It sounds like we're going to go
to the Capitol."
He didn't look up from his phone
and said something
to the effect of,
"There's a lot going on, Cass,
but I don't know.
Things might get real,
real bad on January 6th."
-Man, this dude was checked out
like a substitute teacher
showing his class "Amadeus"
on laserdisc
the day before summer break.
"Hey, Mr. Meadows.
We gonna learn anything today?"
"You're gonna learn what happens
to the human spirit
when you're forced
to toil in the shadow
of a childish show-off."
[ Laughter ]
"Also, you're all
getting an F!
And F. Murray Abraham, that is."
[ Laughter and
scattered applause ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, I'll wait till it gets
what it deserves.
[ Laughter ]
Although in fairness, that is
probably the one and only moment
from all the January 6 hearings
that I related to.
If I had sold my soul
to Donald Trump
and was facing a lifetime
of criminal exposure
and historical disgrace,
I, too, would
check the [bleep] out.
I'd have one of those giant
Costco containers
of cheese balls, except
it'd be filled with Xanax.
So virtually everyone in Trump's
orbit, from his chief of staff
to his weird pillow friend,
is under investigation.
Now, if it feels to you
like every story you hear
about the Republican Party
and conservative movement is
about the deep rot of corruption
at the heart
of GOP institutions,
that's because it's true.
And to drive the point home,
there's a truly insane story
that we're learning
more about this week
that captures
the fundamental truth
about just how corrupt
and morally bankrupt
conservative governance
has become.
The story involves
retired quarterback
and dungarees pitchman
Brett Favre,
millions of dollars that were
supposed to help poor people
in the country's poorest state,
and a shadowy deal to build
a volleyball facility.
-New court documents filed
this week include text messages
that appear to show
Mississippi's former governor
helping NFL Hall of Famer
Brett Favre
secure millions to build
a volleyball facility --
money that came from funds
meant for needy families
in one of the nation's
poorest states.
-The texts appear to show
the former governor,
Phil Bryant, helping Favre
secure millions to build
a volleyball facility
at his alma mater, University
of Southern Mississippi.
And mind you, his daughter
also played volleyball there.
Now, the money was allegedly
earmarked, though,
for family welfare programs
at the state.
-Again, this is federal money
for welfare
for poor Mississippians,
going to a volleyball facility
that Brett Favre's daughter
is going to play in.
The woman who ran the nonprofit,
Nancy New, reportedly coughed up
$4 million
in misused welfare money.
And when that was not enough,
she then allegedly paid Favre --
Brett Favre,
millionaire Brett Favre --
an additional $1.1 million
personally to him,
supposedly for radio ads
paid for out of a fund
for welfare recipients.
-Now, remember, this is
the same state, Mississippi,
that's also been facing
a disastrous water crisis
affecting the majority-Black
city of Jackson.
And yet the state's Republicans
are so cartoonishly corrupt
they stole money
set aside for poor people
and gave it to a multi-
millionaire NFL quarterback.
I think as punishment,
from this point forward,
Favre should not be remembered
for his 16 seasons
with the Green Bay Packers,
but for his one season
with the New York Jets.
I'm sorry, Brett.
Actions have consequences.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Although it should be noted,
they did win
the Super Bowl that year.
I mean, they went 9-7,
but that's like a Super Bowl
for the Jets.
[ Laughter ]
You know, sometimes we have
international viewers
who leave comments for me
and they say, "We really
don't like these Jets jokes,
because obviously
we don't get them."
So just let me explain.
It's gonna take a minute,
and I apologize
for taking time out of the day.
Football is a sport.
The Jets are [bleep]
at football.
[ Laughter ]
But the craziest part
of this scandal is that
Favre turns out to be
just as dumb
as all the other corrupt weirdos
in Trump's orbit.
Because as the deal
was happening,
he apparently wrote
a text message explaining
that he was concerned people
would find out it was happening.
-Texts show Favre was worried
about how it might look.
He wrote,
"If you were to pay me,
is there any way
the media can find out
where it came from
and how much?"
-Yeah.
Yeah, dude, there's a way.
[ Laughter ]
I love that he's asking
if it could ever go public
via a text
that eventually went public.
Was the next text...
This is the rot
and the moral bankruptcy
of conservative governments
at its core.
This is the same
conservative movement
that's hell-bent
on dismantling democracy
and installing themselves
as unelected rulers.
And apparently,
while they were all engaged
in various scandals
and criminal schemes,
they were texting each other
about those scandals
and criminal schemes
and telling each other...
-Don't tell anybody.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
The midterm elections
are coming up.
So to make sure that you're good
to vote in this election,
visit our good friends
at headcount.org
to check your voter
registration status
or to register to vote.